it's not often that you see a gravestone
with a correction on it but then it's
not often that you find a story as
strange as this one I'm just outside
Velva
in southern Spain a little distance away
is the grave of the man who never was in
1943 is the second world war raged on
the body of Major William Martin of the
British Royal Marines was discovered
floating off the coast here chained to
him was a briefcase and in it a letter
with details about the Allied armies
plans to attack Greece across the
Mediterranean Sea it wasn't here all our
secret war plans but it was close it was
a friendly letter between generals that
gave away all the necessary details
British intelligence raced to recover
the briefcase before German spies could
look through it but they were too late
yes Britain got its documents back but
not before a copy of them was on its way
to Hitler who then moved huge numbers of
troops tanks and boats to Greece ready
to repel the British attack Hitler was
probably quite surprised than when the
Allies attacked Sicily of the southern
coast of Italy and not Greece and one
with a fraction of the losses that they
could have suffered there never was any
major William Martin
he was fictional but there was a man
called Glinda Michael it was a Welshman
in London in World War two homeless
penniless friendless he died on the
streets after eating poison perhaps
deliberately perhaps by desperately
eating food that was left out as bait
for rats we'll never know according to
official records his body was removed
out of England and well that's that's
true his body was held in a mortuary for
a while then dressed in the correct
uniform and given painstakingly forged
personal documents a receipt for a
wedding ring a photo and love letter
from a fiance a bus tickets and keys and
other paperwork then the body was put on
board a submarine which sailed to the
coast of Spain and quietly on a dark
night in April 1943 the boat's crew
liked the body drift with the currents
the plan was called rather gruesomely
operation mincemeat British intelligence
had chosen their target well Spain had
plenty of German spies and the Spanish
head of intelligence was a sort of man
who had claimed the discovery as his own
and that traveled to Berlin to deliver a
copy personally and perhaps even
embellished the story a little
how it was found to make himself look
better and the tip seemed a bit more
credible which he did and of course all
the desperate British efforts to recover
the documents were a sham by 1943 the
team at Bletchley Park had cracked the
Enigma cipher and we're listening to
German communications less than a month
after Glenda's body had been released
the codebreakers intercepted a signal
that showed that the scheme had worked
perfectly Britain took Sicily used as a
beachhead to get to Italy and German war
plans were in tatters major Martin by
then had been buried with full military
honors and an appropriate gravestone the
truth was still top-secret and it wasn't
until decades later that his real
identity was revealed and so the grave
was corrected blinnder Michel served as
Major William Martin rest in peace
you